hi this is preshtalwalker
this riddle is a logic puzzle and it
assumes that the characters can reason
with absolute precision so pay attention
to the details of the story
alice and bob are trapped by an evil
logician
in their cells alice can see exactly 12
trees and bob can see exactly eight
trees
they're told that together they can see
all the trees in the prison but that no
tree is seen by both people
neither person knows how many trees the
other person sees
every day the logician visits alice
inner cell in the morning and asks are
there 18 or 20 trees in total
if alice knows the answer she can say
but if she doesn't know then she's going
to pass
in that case
the logician then goes visits bob in his
cell and then asks the same question
if bob knows he can give the answer
otherwise he also is going to pass
if they both pass then the same process
is repeated the next day
now at some point they're going to want
to guess because they don't want to keep
passing and staying in prison forever
however if either person doesn't know
and they guess incorrectly then they're
both going to be imprisoned forever
if either person does know and guesses
correctly then they're both going to be
set free immediately
now they can't communicate with each
other the number of trees that they see
but the question is can they do better
than random chance can they do better
than just guessing 18 or 20. if they
both understand the rules of the game
can they escape and reason their way out
with certainty
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
so at first it seems impossible alice
just sees 12 trees so she doesn't know
if they're 18 or 20 trees and bob only
sees eight trees so he doesn't know if
they're 18 or 20 trees and it doesn't
seem like they can ever figure it out
because all they see is the number of
trees in front of them
however what happens is that each day
when they give an answer that actually
conveys information to the other person
so let's start out on day one
when alice is asked the question do you
see 18 or 20 trees
if she saw 19 or 20 trees she could
exclude the answer of 18 and she could
actually conclude that there were 20
trees
what alice does see is she only sees 12
trees so she has to pass
however the fact that she passes
actually conveys to bob
that alice is not seeing 19 or 20 trees
she actually sees at most 18 trees
so this information gets conveyed to bob
if bob only saw zero or one trees
knowing that alice saw
at most 18 trees bob could conclude that
there were 18 trees
however bob sees more than zero one
trees he actually sees eight trees so
he's not sure if they're 18 or 20 trees
so he's going to want to pass
but the fact that he passes actually
relays the information to alice that
alice says all right logically bob must
not have seen zero or one trees he must
have seen at least two trees
so we've actually gained some
information on the fact that each person
has passed on day one
and this information can be built upon
on day two
now alice knows that bob sees at least
two trees
so if alice saw 17 or 18 trees she would
actually know that there would have to
be 20 trees
however since alice only sees 12 trees
she once again has to pass but that
conveys to bob that bob realizes all
right alice must not have seen 17 or 18
trees she must have seen at most 16
trees
knowing this if bob saw two or three
trees
then bob would actually be able to say
alright there must be 18 trees because
20 trees would not be possible 2 or 3
plus 16 would never get to 20.
but since bob sees actually eight trees
he can't exclude that possibility so he
still thinks there could be 18 or 20.
but because he passes that conveys
information to alice that bob must see
at least four trees
we can continue the logic for the next
day
if bob sees at least four trees if alice
saw 15 or 16 trees she could exclude the
possibility that there were only 18
trees and she would conclude that there
are 20 trees
once again alice only sees 12 trees so
she has to pass
but the act of passing actually conveys
information that bob is saying all right
if she passes on day three that means
she has to see at most 14 trees
bob can take that information and if he
saw four or five trees knowing alice saw
at most 14 then he would be able to
exclude the possibility of 20 and say
they're only 18 trees but once again bob
sees eight trees so he's going to pass
and that conveys information that alice
says all right bob must have seen at
least six trees otherwise he would have
said there were 18.
this brings us to day four where we
continue the logic if alice saw only 13
or 14 trees knowing bob saw at least six
then she would be able to exclude 18 and
say there must be 20 trees
but since alice only sees 12 trees she's
going to pass once again and that
conveys information to bob that alice
sees at most 12 trees
so if alice saw at most 12 trees and he
saw six or seven he would be able to
exclude 20 and say there must be 18
trees
since he sees eight trees he has to pass
and that conveys to alice that bob must
see at least eight trees
and now we actually get to the result in
day five
alice knows that she sees twelve trees
and bob sees at least eight trees so she
can exclude the possibility of 18 trees
she can conclude there must be 20 trees
in total so on day 5 in the morning
alice says there are 20 trees she is
correct and they are both set free
forever
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel and make videos
on math and game theory you can catch me
on my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description